Dai dai dai
che cosa Lex
[Musica]
in trappola l'ho chiuso fuori nel
terrazzo di certo non può saltare giù
perché non può saltare come noi i gatti
dall'alto si sfracellerebbe quindi è
semplicemente intrappola qua ora devo
continuare i miei piani
mi ha chiuso fuori Mi ha chiuso fuori la
mia unica salvezza adesso è l'ex Alex
non mi voleva aiutare Spero sia ancora
qui magari riesci a sentirmi Alexa
aiuto mix dove sei l'ex
Ciao lex ma di nuovo mi ha chiamato di
nuovo Aiutami ha chiuso fuori
sì Mi puoi aprire per favore ti abbiamo
detto che non ne voglio sentire dico la
storia Grazie
di questa storia non le voglio sapere
niente E come potevo fare Mi aveva
chiuso là fuori non vedi Sono disperato
Non lo riconosco nemmeno più Ogni volta
Questa stessa storia mi devi aiutare per
forza io non la riconosco più Anita
questa trasformazione l'ha cambiata
profondamente non riesco più a vederla
in faccia nemmeno mi fa troppo paura te
l'ho detto il gatto mannaro è una
creatura molto molto più forte eh sì me
ne sono accorto però adesso ho bisogno
del tuo aiuto da solo non ci riesco ma
cosa non hai capito del No dai l'ex Ti
prego ti prego Dai aiutami aiutami dai
mettiti posso aiutare in qualche modo io
anche poi dopo il ricambio il favore
ad esempio non lo so Magari magari hai
bisogno di qualcosa che che non hai è
che io posso darti se ricordo bene
l'altra volta era interessato a quelle
ricette proibite nel mondo delle
Creature magari io te le posso fare
avere Che ne pensi le ricette del libro
di fiamma dici Esatto hai visto già
adesso sto convincendo Dai dammi una
mano aiutami
[Musica]
effettivamente quelle Potrebbero
servirmi Oh bene Vedi Dai di Quale
ricetta hai bisogno del
mio film no no no no no no no no no il
Distruggi i mostri delle Creature cosa
no no no no no no no Tu hai detto filtro
d'amore ti ho sentito Eh hai bisogno di
un filtro d'amore no no no no no no no
no no no no no no devi fare innamorare
qualcuno io sono un mostro robot è
importante tutto di un pezzo non ho il
tempo per queste cose Sì sì va bene va
bene dai Intanto Dammi una mano con
Anita come possiamo fare adesso a patto
che tu mi dai il foglio
va bene siamo d'accordo Ma hai appena
detto che
[Musica]
prego
non mi interessa non mi interessa Sì sì
te lo prometto te lo prometto
Questa è una promessa è una promessa Ok
allora ti aiuterò da sconfiggere Anita
grazie grazie Sei troppo forte come
facciamo adesso allora il piano più
semplice e credo anche il più efficace
sarà attirarla in trappola in trappola
Guardate Ma è un topolino Non è solo un
topolino magari per lei è solo un
topolino ma per noi è la nostra
occasione per catturarla Va bene va bene
Eh come come dobbiamo fare allora va
attiviamo la chiamiamo e gli diciamo Eh
guarda c'è un topolino noi useremo il
controller per muovere il topolino dove
vogliamo dove vogliamo tirarla dove la
vogliamo attirare qua in questa stanza
Eh penso proprio di sì è un'ottima idea
è così una volta tirata qui noi potremmo
cercare l'antidoto per farla tornare
normale Giusto esattamente Uh grande hai
visto Sembra una squadra fantastica e
vai Ricordati quella pagina del libro La
pagina Ah sì certo certo andiamo Sì sì
andiamo Andiamo
adesso Io sono pronto Tu sei pronto sono
bruttissimo Allora appoggiamo il topo
qui vai tu guida eh guida bene penso io
ok Vado allora
[Musica]
devo aver sbagliato qualcosa il giorno
che dovevo prendere la patente dei
topini non ci sono andato la patente dei
topini Ma stai scherzando guidi un
topolino senza avere la patente non hai
passato l'esame non hai passato l'esame
pratico o teorico Eh no non ho passato
quello pratico perché vedi Te lo ricordi
ce l'ho e le cose che so che me ne vado
guido io che ce la patente tra Bravo
bravo Allora pronti
Abbassa le orecchie ho paura che ci
rotola Grazie
Guarda hai visto bravo dai dai dai
[Musica]
Dimmi
è entrato in camera Sì dai dai andiamo a
chiuderlo Adesso andiamo andiamo andiamo
Chiudi chiudi l'abbiamo bloccato
[Applauso]
Adesso però dobbiamo cercare l'antidoto
dai sbrighiamoci a cercarlo andiamo
andiamo andiamo
adesso che abbiamo rinchiuso Anita
possiamo finalmente mangiare Ma cosa
mangiare no no mangiamo Adesso mangiamo
dopo Ah ok Scusa volevo dire troviamo
l'anti
concentrati
per trasformare Anita Infatti ritornare
Anita normale bravissimo Ah ce l'ho
fatta Ok quindi primo passo trovare il
diario di fiamma sì e dovrebbe essere
qui in giro dobbiamo solo cercare un
attimino Tu video mani si sono
dimenticati che Coazze il terrazzo e noi
gatti possiamo saltare dai terrazzi
senza farci niente
cadiamo sempre in piedi
[Musica]
Dove sono andati quei due
cerchiamoli ho fame
Ecco vedi qui c'è la ricetta
dell'ululato e la variante del gatto e
la variante del gatto quella che la
trasforma in mannaro Sì da Adesso
proviamo a girare vediamo se troviamo
l'antidoto
[Musica]
Conosci questi mostri e che cosa fa
paura ai gatti non ti viene in mente
niente è un qualcosa per poterlo creare
noi magari l'antidoto ti sei anche
dimenticato che sono un mostro provo e
quindi la risposta
c'è davvero e Certo che ce l'ho e qual è
la risposta i gatti hanno paura di due
cose Oh e quali sono queste due cose
Adesso prova a pensarci un gatto quando
vede l'acqua che cosa fa il gatto ha
paura dell'acqua bravo e l'altra Qual è
Hai paura dei cani Ma no non hanno paura
di cani almeno non tutti È vero non
tutti C'è un'altra cosa quella forse non
la sai no Dimmelo i limoni limoni Perché
i gatti hanno paura dei Limoni Sì non è
che hanno proprio paura della forma
tonda di un limone giallo Ok che è acido
e quando lo annusano gli da fastidio Ma
sei grande lex Certo sono uno psicologo
Allora ascolta non ci resta altro che
andare a cercare fuori un limone e poi
prendere dell'acqua e portarla sopra
dalle dita giusto Sì è un piano è un
ottimo piano Ok ma dobbiamo curare le
devi recitare una formula tipo cantare
con una gamba alzata o qualcosa del
genere Oppure basta lanciarmi addosso
così no no no no no non stiamo parlando
di una formula o di una pozione dobbiamo
semplicemente
lanciare l'acqua con i limoni ad Anita e
speriamo che funzioni perché me lo
auguro Non è detto Non è detto come non
è detto dici tanto lo farei tu quindi
sei pronto sono prontissimo andiamo
andiamo
Next vediamo di là Dai andiamo andiamo
andiamo allora non è questo dobbiamo
cercare i limoni qui Qui ci sono degli
alberi ma non vedo dei Limoni quindi
dobbiamo provare ad alzare da quella
parte Andiamo dai ti seguo
ma abbiamo chiuso bene Anita Sì
adesso che ci penso Sì l'avevo chiusa
bene l'abbiamo chiusa a chiave Ti
ricordo ora siamo tranquilli dai andiamo
a prendere questi colpi però eh con
tutta calma ma ascolta Visto che tu sei
un mezzo lupo e un mezzo cane mezzo
umano non potresti usare il tuo fiuto
per sentire Dove sono i limoni Ottima
idea allora vediamo per fortuna che ci
sono io l'ex c'hai ragione e poi chiami
sempre a me però vero vero Dai allora da
quale parte dobbiamo andare l'ex
[Musica]
ma aspetta sei tu aspetta aspetta
dovresti farti una doccia Ok grazie
Alexa sento qualcosa che cosa senti
adesso quella direzione Ok andiamo l'ex
Ma sei sicuro che qui sì è una
cassaforte ho sentito odore di frutti
Vediamo Ah sì l'ex questi sono dei
frutti Eh però non sono limoni vedi che
sono delle albicocche
ma il mio naso ha sbagliato Beh sì è
vero che l'albicocca è un po' acida però
non è acida come un limone Ah è pure
Strano il mio olfatto non sbaglia mai
C'è qualcosa di strano
c'è qualche altro odore ma sembra un
odore di gatto
proprio qui Ah certo ecco perché E
allora ho sbagliato dobbiamo andare da
qualche altra parte ma
ci si è spostato Sì e io lo sento ancora
tantissimo Cioè mi stai dicendo che
senti l'odore di gatto ancora qui
C'è qualcosa di strano
che cosa Lex
[Musica]
PS
la mia sorpresa
devo andare devo scappare
non ti posso aiutare Ho troppa paura dei
gatti mannari troverò un modo per
aiutarti Alex sono scappare le ex
scappa pure lupo ci penso io a Vitale no
che cosa vuoi farmi
Che paura il gatto mannaro dove non
pensavo di vederlo mai il gatto mannaro
Cosa posso fare come faccio ad aiutare
i limoni io posso continuare il nostro
piano anche se lui è stato catturato io
posso continuare i limoni devo trovare i
limoni
da questa parte
Eccoli limoni li ho trovati il mio fiuto
non sbaglia mai vediamo come faccio a
prenderlo
Ah ci sono riuscito ecco un limone
adesso posso continuare col piano
aiuterò sia Vitale che Anita andiamo ce
la posso fare
[Musica]
ok Adesso che ho il limone mi mancava
soltanto l'acqua Ehi aspetta C'è
un'altra cosa che devo fare Mi sono
dimenticato che hanno indagato mannaro e
di là con Vitale devo trovare un modo
per farla avvicinare qua Cosa posso
usare
Ah certo l'erba gatta quindi il piano è
cambiato con il mio fiuto troverò l'erba
gatta per avvicinare Anita metterò il
limone nell'acqua e poi su
e spero tanto che funzioni Beh non ho
molta altra scelta è meglio che mi
spiriti
avrei catturato alla fine il tuo amico
lupo è stato inutile
Non tornerà più a salvarsi
Beh perché un fifone Ha paura di me e di
tutti i gatti e come lo chiami un lupo
del genere un fifone
dove credi di andare da nessuna parte
Sono solo cercando di scappare
l'erba gatta
andare a prendere l'acqua e mettere i
limoni
vado
che c'è
Dove stiamo andando a mangiare
piano però mi fai male con quegli
artigli
[Musica]
l'erba gatta
ce l'ho fatta Ragazzi cosa avete fatto
perché mi avete buttato l'acqua addosso
Ecco guarda ero un po' una situazione un
po' particolare abbiamo dovuto
intervenire per forza così
è uno scherzo
Non c'è nessuno scherzo non c'è ma
guarda che ti abbiamo salvato Eh a me
sembra solo che mi avete tirato un
gavettone d'acqua in testa per quale
motivo eh per salvarti ti abbiamo
salvato sì È una lunga storia e adesso
non ho il tempo io devo tornare in
vacanza Beh Vitale Ricordati di mandarmi
quella cosa che mi hai promesso vorrei
Certo certo la ciotola di crocchetta
Come no
immaginate Sì sì d'amore
ricordate
Ciao Anita Io devo andare ciao ciao Max
grazie grazie
ciao divertiti in vacanza certo
e Ok ciao Next Ciao Mi devi spiegare
bene che cosa è successo Perché mi avete
fatto questo gavettone d'acqua guarda
Dopo ti racconterò Non ti preoccupare
Hai sentito anche tu sì proveniva da
dentro casa andiamo
a vedere
[Musica]